the first thing you understand before
looking at cars to drive themselves is
just how much of our lives cars have
become especially in the United States
but really all around the world there
are 33,000 Americans killed every year
in car accidents more killed in car
accidents in the United States than in
its entire history of war going back to
the Revolutionary War
we have 1.2 million people killed around
the world it's one of the world's major
diseases if it were a disease in terms
of killing people and we also give 25
percent of all of our energy to personal
transportation and 25 percent of our
greenhouse gases are going to the car
now this is not true in Manhattan but in
Los Angeles it's estimated that more
than half of the land in the city
belongs to the cars garages it's
driveways its roads its parking lots all
these things land that belongs to the
car we have given up so much of
ourselves and we depend on the car for
so much it's shaped our cities it's
shaped our lives the fact that now cars
are going to be a computer thing that
the computer is going to be the most
important part of the car the thing that
drives the car will be more important
than the engine and this will be on the
Moore's Law curve we've talked about
getting better
not the engine getting better every year
but the important part that drives it
getting better every year the way
computer technology and network
technology do we're going to rewrite
really important elements of our society
when we make transportation one of these
computerized technologies so most people
thought that cars that drive themselves
or something from science fiction I
still routinely run into people say this
is not in my lifetime 20 or 30 years
away but this is clearly wrong and it's
becoming more and more clearly wrong as
time goes on the most famous project and
the most advanced project has come not
from a car company but from Google and I
worked actually on Google's team for a
while and building that vehicle so they
have both logged about 700,000 miles of
driving on ordinary city streets with
their vehicles and they've now just
released in May of 2014 they have
released a new vehicle that they're
building from scratch designing from
scratch which has no steering wheel in
it no pedals you just get in and you've
given it a destiny
probably on your phone and away it goes
and takes you there and that's the real
game changer when it comes out the car
companies also are all working on
efforts every major car company has
announced some sort of effort and Nissan
and Mercedes and Volvo have all
announced they'll be selling cars about
2020 that look a little bit more like
traditional cars but what Google's car
does it's a vehicle that can run with Oh
steering wheel and nothing can run
unmanned and that's where it gets really
interesting because the vehicle that can
run on its own is a vehicle that can
deliver itself to you it's a vehicle
that can refuel or recharge itself
without you having to worry about it and
it's a vehicle that can store or what we
used to call Park itself although it may
mostly function as a taxi and as a taxi
it wouldn't even park at all it would
just go and pick up the next person it
has to pick up so today when people buy
a car they go into the car dealership
and they look for a multi-purpose car
they ask what car do I need for my life
because they think well I ski twice a
year so I need an SUV even though I live
in the city I need an SUV to get me up
to the mountains every so often or the
number one selling car in America the
Ford f-150 pickup truck which is not
what most of those people need but we
all go and buy at least a five passenger
sedan a multi-purpose car for all of our
needs when you think of cars as fungible
objects almost that can be delivered on
demand because you pick up a cell phone
and you ask a car to come to you well
suddenly you don't have to get a
multi-purpose car you can get a car for
that trip the car that you need today
the car that you need right now that is
a very different car from the cars we've
made for the last century these big fat
boxy things this is a car most of the
time for one person because almost all
your trips are alone sorry unless you're
a very friendly person they're alone and
they're just short trips across town but
we buy a car that's able to take five
people hundreds of miles and that's very
wasteful it's very energy inefficient it
takes a lot of space on the road too so
if most trips come in little small
electric vehicles in particular that are
good enough for one person or two people
face-to-face and they have a desk in
them and a screen so that you can work
watch videos and do things and takes no
time it's a very different vision of
Transportation and it's a much lower
energy vision of Transportation
particularly as you enable electric
vehicles now today people don't buy
electric vehicles that much they buy
something there's certainly some some
press being made about it but it's it's
really a small portion of the car market
and they are worried that the car will
run out of range or it'll take hours to
recharge it when they're done they you
know don't want a hassle of plugging it
in but a robot doesn't care about any of
those hassles and a robot doesn't care
about anything and because of that you
can get a vehicle that is electric
because you don't care about the range
you don't care about the powertrain at
all it's very different from the way
cars are sold today so we have lots of
small efficient vehicles these vehicles
are so efficient that they don't just
beat out the cars were riding in now
they beat out the trains and the buses
even in Manhattan even in Japan that's
how efficient small lightweight electric
vehicles can be at carrying people in
terms of energy used to send a person a
mile so this would mean the United
States would no longer have to import
oil from overseas and you've probably
seen there's a pesky habit that the US
has of going to war over the oil imports
from overseas be very nice habit to be
broken of it also means reducing
greenhouse gas emissions by 200 million
tons it means getting rid of all the
parking lots we have in our cities
because if we don't have to store
vehicles in the same way suddenly
there's a land bonanza in so many towns
maybe not the dense downtown part but
all of the surrounding territory there's
so much of that land is parking lots and
for cars suddenly we're gonna turn some
parking lots into parkland that's gonna
be pretty nice we also have tricks to
deal with congestion and that's pretty
big if you invest in real estate you
probably have heard a mantra that says
the value of real estate is based on
three important factors right it's an
old joke real location location and
location we're going to change what
location means because transportation is
really what locations about is having a
short trip farther on foot or on wheels
or in transit or other things to the
things in your life that you need to get
to
shops and the people and the work the
whole nature of retailing is going to
change because we're also gonna build
delivery robots that never carry a
person and they're small and they're
very very cheap and they can get you
anything in 30 minutes not just a pizza
now we do have a society that's decided
the pizza is the most important thing in
the world you have to be able to get it
in 30 minutes no matter when no matter
where you are but what if you can get
anything cheaply in 30 minutes what does
that mean for shopping for retailing
for how we use goods how we own goods
it's going to change a lot more of our
lives than people think
to have cars that are smart in this way
a lot of people want to know when this
is going to come out and you know I make
jokes about naming a specific day and
time
so we've seen forecasts from many
different companies Sergey Brin first
said Google he thought would have cars
in people's hands in 2017 widespread
deployment not then but was happening in
the later part of this decade and real
deployment in the early part of the
2020s the car companies have said 2020
is sort of their target year most of
them have said that although Tesla
because Elon Musk the CEO of Tesla has
the largest testicles of anyone in
Silicon Valley he said he thinks he's
gonna have a car in 2016 we'll see if he
delivers on that well though though has
also said they'll have cars running
around their headquarters town in the
hands of civilians in 2017 so there's a
lot of people willing to make
predictions for release quick delivery
now will they spread like wildfire like
smartphones or will they spread like
electric cars really really slowly well
I'm betting on more like smart phones
but that's not a bet that anyone can
promise the answer to we're not talking
about vehicles that will be perfect it
would be hubris to suggest they could be
perfect there will be accidents there
will be injuries and there could
unfortunately even be fatalities and we
do have a strong fear of being hurt by
machines and good reason it's something
to be afraid of but the social question
is if you don't like being killed by
robots you'd rather be killed by drums
because that's what's happening today
40% of the fatalities on the roads here
are have drinking involved in them and
robots for better or worse very rarely
drink
they'll make mistakes but for different
reasons and so as a society it's an
interesting question something you're
very scared of but which is actually
safer on the grow hole it's nobody's
gonna release this technology until
they've got the evidence to themselves
their lawyers to the public that is
doing a better job than people are at
driving so you've got something that is
better than people but it's more
frightening and you could indeed see
societies jumping back from that
however whichever country decides to
jump back another country will jump in
and there are many countries which can
change their laws and their liabilities
and their rules very quickly in a way
that the United States maybe can't and
so there will be global competition to
see who rules the new car industry and I
really mean the car industry there is a
lesson that we teach over in Silicon
Valley about what's called disruptive
technology and when we go through
disruptive change in a technology it's
very uncommon for the big players from
the earlier generation to make it
through to the the new world and how
many of you are using a Kodak camera for
example not too many so I fear for the
car companies because they will die some
of them as we move to this new world and
the places where cars are made may shift
you know Detroit has a big challenge in
front of it and it's gonna face against
wherever the new industry comes from but
Japan Korea Germany they also need to be
afraid and they're the centres of car
manufacturing today but politicians
actually are aware of this and they're
interested in seeing ways to make sure
that their economy becomes dominant in
this world and that's why they've
already passed laws in several states
and now in other places around the world
to enable this technology rather than
slowing down
you